hi there i'm shea coulee and i'm here
with buzzfeed reading all of my thirst
tweets
[Music]
shea coulee's all-stars finale look was
gag
work the blue wig the dress the b heart
eye emoji heart eye emoji heart eye
emoji
i'm looking at this tweet and to be
perfectly honest not a single
lie was detected so thank you for coming
on twitter and
being a truth teller because honestly i
go on twitter
to just start fights and lie i have to
watch the sasha velour and shake who lay
so emotional lip sync at least once a
day for a serotonin boost
i don't really know much about serotonin
but if that
gives you a serotonin boost then by all
means girl get your booze
once a day so emotional shay coulee the
thing that was going through my head
during that lip sync was damn i can't
believe this [ __ ] just littered the
stage with all these slippery rose
petals
i need to listen to another podcast no
am i listening to shay coulee and nicole
buyer talk about top model anyway
you bet your ass thank you so much for
listening
to my brand new podcast wanna be on top
a
podcast dedicated to the cultural
phenomenon
that launched a thousand smizes
america's next top model
called me old-fashioned but i was raised
to serve
shay coulee cook her meals and clean her
clothes i do whatever she says
she makes the rules she owns me i am
her property her needs come first
and if she cheats that's on me she
caught me lacking
okay well please send your resume to
gimmesh.com i need all these things
and i do have a lot of clothes and they
do need laundry you need to tell me
though how you fold your towels because
i'm specific about that but if you're
willing to learn then by all means send
your resume over to me if she could
walk the runway in garbage bags i would
simply defend it like it was the most
stunning look of all time and you're
right because on me it would be the most
stunning look of all time obviously she
understands
shea coulee is a drag queen like
she is flawless from head to toe she is
fashion
she is camp she gives fish and she's a
lip sync assassin
shakes late is opulence i really don't
know like how
thirsty that would be but i do love
validation and you gave me a lot there
girl so i will take it
shane coulee really been living in my
mind rent free after that iconic walk at
the savage fenty show
i know right i know thank you for giving
me space rent free because i'm really
not trying
to pay additional rent i really feel
like i'm in the moment in my life where
i'm trying to pay a mortgage
so if you do have a whole entire house
in which i can mortgage in your head
with that walk then by all means hit me
up let me know
world of chez coulee presents shea
coulee's drag race airing exclusively on
shake lay or available for streaming on
shea coulee presents plus yes
yes yes to all of that yes you can
stream
shay coulee on shay coulee presents drag
race shake flakes miss leon shake away
presents plus
and it is only 2.99 a month i want
shake late runway stomp over my unworthy
body fine if that's what you want i will
have no problem doing that but just tell
me um what shoes you want me to wear
i love how we as a community with all of
our differences
agree that shay coulee is really truly
holy and flawlessly that
wow you know what i am a firm believer
in community and i am so proud to belong
to a community
that knows that i am that
not to be horny on main but how tall is
shae goulet
i am five nine but depending on the
heels how high you want them
girl i could be six four jay coulee's
ass and she knows
i would like to thank uh macaroni and
cheese mashed potatoes
dill pickled flavored chips that you can
only get at whole foods
and fried chicken shake away could hit
me with her car
reverse hit me again and i would
enthusiastically thank her
most people would file a lawsuit but
i appreciate you showing gratitude
i want shay coulee to suffocate me
with her boobs i don't
have boobs i couldn't suffocate a
mosquito with these
okay but i could suffocate you with that
ass ah
shea coulee is one thick b
let me see that
not with not with you asking like that
your mouth okay so this is the very last
one
i love shaku like so much i would
legit let her stab me to death and use
my corpse as a tape
um look i'm open to a lot of things
however um murder and human taxidermy
aren't two of the things on my list so i
will politely have to decline i would be
willing to meet you for coffee in a
public place with many witnesses
so there you go thank you so much for
all of your thirst suites i had so much
fun
with you all at buzzfeed today and
remember to catch my new podcast
want to be on top wherever you listen to
your podcast
every monday and thursday
[Music]
you